so I'm going to talk more on the bonus
show about my vacation Pat's going to
talk about his vacation during the break
I posted a bunch of pictures from my
trip to Belgium on my Instagram account
which is David Pakman and you know a lot
of people liked my posts Pat but a ton
of people had criticisms no matter what
I post to Instagram there are people who
tell me I am doing something very very
wrong so let's start with the first
picture here I'll describe the picture
and then I'll tell you what was wrong so
this is a picture of me reading outdoors
at a cafe in Brussels Belgium right not
controversial you would think criticisms
that people sent in I shouldn't be
reading in the Sun because I'm
scrunching my eyes books that long it's
a very long book are a waste of time and
reading on vacations is a waste of time
period I should be doing other things
after all I'm on a trip I completely
reject that I like to have time to read
books when I'm on a trip this is a
Bertrand Russell's a history of Western
philosophy it is a very very long book
and I was enjoying myself
reading you know what why am I always
doing something wrong in the eyes of
people well perhaps the person
accompanying you at the table there is
forward because you have a book to read
and maybe that person doesn't have
anything for them my girlfriend had her
own book she was just taking a short
break to take a picture of me so anyway
there I was doing something wrong next
picture that people really liked for my
Instagram account this is me at a
brewery tour Belgium has excellent beer
I did a couple of brewery tours I
thought hey Here I am
where they are storing the beer people
are going to like this and people did
but no there were criticisms Pat people
saying David those don't look like beer
barrels they look like wine barrels
people don't aged beer in barrels like
that well this brewery did this brewery
did some people commenting saying David
drinking is bad you shouldn't be
drinking at all and other people saying
David Belgian beer isn't even that good
German beer is better but you were in
Belgium I wasn't yeah I wasn't going to
go to any german breweries when I was in
Belgium and then lastly people really
liking this I went to Belgian I had the
famous Belgian frites we know them as
French fries here the criticisms were I
went to the wrong frites place how you
can tell from this picture I
no fried foods are bad for you and
Belgian frites are typically fried in
duck fat so they aren't vegetarian I
actually don't know if that's true I
didn't inquire about that and lastly
that ketchup is a lame topping even
though it was curry ketchup not regular
ketchup but mostly people seem to like
it I guess it's just someone will have a
problem with what I'm doing no matter
what it is yeah because when you were
reading a book it looked as if you are
working too hard on your vacation and
maybe looking a little bit too elitist
and now you're drinking and eating fried
foods so you can't you try to get
balanced at least yeah but clearly I did
everything wrong on this vacation anyway
I'll talk more about the trip will hear
about Pat's
excellent adventure on the bonus show as
well and you can follow me on instagram
at david pakman